depuis ce matin 9h c'est un débat
passionné qui s'est ouvert à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés se penchent sur le
Pax le pacte civil de solidarité qui
vise à accorder aux couplle ou aux
personnes en communauté de vie un statut
légal quelques 900 amendements ont été
déposés principalement par l'opposition
le rapporteur ce matin s'est défendu de
toute arrière-pensée Dominique martinau
Benoît
verérrand c'est très irrité que le RPR
envisageait ce matin l'ouverture de ce
débat sur le Pax comme le gouvernement
n'est pas content d'avoir une opposition
il a décidé de la faire travailler
jusqu'à 7h du matin et par conséquent
nous qui avons au RPR nos journées
parlementaires à Menton ça va être un
véritable marathon et bien nous pensons
que ce n'est pas une bonne moyen un bon
moyen en tous les cas de respecter
l'opposition c'est pas un bon moyen de
travailler non plus pour faire avancer
un sujet de société qui est difficile et
délicat face à une quinzaine de députés
de gauche et une trentaine à droite très
remonté le Guer des saau a réaffirmé que
le le Pax n'était pas un mariage bis
mais une nouvelle forme de
solidarité c'est un texte qui ouvre des
droits nouveau sans en
supprimer il est une avancée sociale
parce qu'il encourage la stabilité il
est une avancée morale parce qu'il
encourage la
solidarité à droite Chahu bien sûr on ne
veut rien entendre décideré à jouer
l'opposition jusqu'au bout avec toutes
les procédures habitu
Mo j'ai une très simple dans cetteaire
consiste à dire le PA n'est pas la
réponse au problème que pose notre
société ce qu'il faut c'est rénover le
mariage et adapter le droit de façon à
l'adapter à l'évolution notre société la
notion de couple en France mais sur les
ban de la droite ce matin on noté
certaines absences très RAR il est vrai
qui approuve ce texte comme Roseline
bachel CIT d'ailleurs en exemple ce
matin par ministre de
et comme finalité de l'action